The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So a couple
of announcements.
Weekly quiz Tuesday.
And also on Tuesday, I want to
draw your attention to the
event in the slide.
We have a poster here for a
lecture that will occur right
in this room, at 4:00
on Tuesday.
And it's entitled the
Wolf Lecture.
The Wolf Lecture was established
here about 30
years ago in honor of
Professor John Wolf.
John Wolf was an antecedent
of mine.
He was the person that
invented 3091.
And in 1961, he dared, as a
metallurgist, to launch a
variant of freshman chemistry.
And you're the beneficiaries
of John Wolf's initiative.
And he also was a spectacular
teacher, quite a showman.
And in his honor, they
instituted in the Department
of Material Science and
Engineering, the Wolf Lecture,
which, as the poster says, is
the entire community is
invited to attend, but it's
geared towards freshman.
So this is a lecture
that the rules are.
Talk about whatever you want in
terms of material science
and engineering, but make it
entertaining, and make it
engaging and accessible
to freshmen.
You should go to lectures.
If you can't go to this
one, then by all
means, go to other seminars.
If all you do when you come to
MIT is go to class, you're
missing out on some of
the richness here.
We have all sorts of people
coming through here every day.
And you can go to these
seminars, you can learn a lot.
You might say, well, I'm just
a freshman, I'm not going to
understand everything.
I go to these things.
I don't understand everything.
But I learn something, because
the first few minutes of the
lecture, if the speaker is any
good, he or she is going to
set up the topic for you.
If you follow the first five
minutes, you'll have something
that, you know, gets you
oriented to the topic.
And then the other thing, the
other reason to go-- you see
this on the poster--
room 10-250, reception
immediately following.
That means there will
be refreshments!
Food, for that, you know,
pick-me-up in the late afternoon.
So you go to the seminar, you
know, sometimes they have
refreshments before
the speaker.
I'm not going to tell you have
to go into the seminar, having
eaten the food and partaken
of the refreshments.
You didn't hear me say that.
But anyways, there's always
food around here.
Go to this one.
I think you'll enjoy it.
And the speaker is Professor
Michael Rubner.
He's a faculty member
in course 3.
An excellent teacher.
As you see, MacVicar Faculty
Fellow, which means he's been
acknowledged as a
good teacher.
I think you'll learn a lot.
And he's talking about
nature-inspired, so
biomimetics, how we see things
in nature and then mimic that
design in advanced
material science.
OK.
Enough said.
Let's get on with the lesson.
Last day we started looking at
solutions, and we recognized
that bonding is the key to
understanding, and it's
encapsulated in that catch-all
phrase, like dissolves like.
And towards the end, we talked
about Ksp as a metric that
helps us understand
common ion effect.
Common ion effect, again, if I
tell you you have, say, 100
units of sodium chloride that
can go into solution, you
would say, that's the
solubility limit.
But then if I tell you, I've
got a solution that already
contains 25 units of sodium
chloride, that's a no-brainer.
You've only got another
75 units to go.
Now I say I've got potassium
chloride in there.
So now you stop and think,
wait a minute.
It's not sodium chloride,
but it is a chloride.
How do I think about this?
Common ion effect through Ksp
helps you reason through it.
It's when you have more than
one solute, and one of the
constituents of the solute
is already present.
So today I want to talk about a
subset of solutions, and in
particular, I want to talk
about acids and bases.
And this is important, not only
in materials processing,
but we're going to have to
understand this if we're going
to go forward later and talk
about biochemistry.
So, you know, they're around
us everywhere.
You know, you probably got up
this morning, you washed your
hair with a pH-balanced shampoo,
maybe had orange
juice or grapefruit juice with
citric and ascorbic acid.
Your radio is powered by zinc
alkaline batteries.
I started my car, it's got the
lead acid battery in it, and
electricity for all my
appliances came from
coal-fired power plants,
spewing out SO2,
turning out acid rain.
So we're off to a good start!
It's Friday.
So now we want to go
back and understand
this from the beginning.
So we're going to start
with a history lesson.
And the history lesson starts
in ancient times.
Acids were known all the way
back in early times for
processing of food
and materials.
So who among us hasn't
eaten something
that has been pickled?
Pickle means to have been
processed in acid solution.
In fact, the word acid comes
from the word acidus in Latin,
and acidus means either
sour or tart.
But the modern chemistry of
acids and bases starts with
Lavoisier in France in 1779.
And I'm going to be naming many
scientists from different
countries today, so I'm
going to use the
international symbol.
You know, these ovals that you
put on the back of the car, so
now if you see a car with
this on it, you know
it's a French registry.
So he's probably got a Peugeot,
and he's driving
around with his Peugeot.
And what Lavoisier said, in
trying to understand acids and
bases, is--
it's a really interesting
story.
He said that oxygen is
present in all acids.
And why?
Because he spent most of his
career studying combustion, so
he was very concerned
about oxygen.
And the interesting thing is
that oxygen, the name of the
gas, oxygen, actually comes
from the greek oxy, which
means sharp, and, you know,
the particle gen, as in to
generate or to be born.
OK?
So it's interesting that this
gas is named incorrectly.
It's named for an attribute that
is ascribed to acid, and
it's wrong.
And it's in other
languages, too.
The word oxygen translates
into other languages as
meaning something sharp, and it
has nothing to do with it.
But while we're on the topic
of Lavoisier, Lavoisier did
study oxygen.
And there was an intense rivalry
between Lavoisier in
France, Joseph Priestley
in Britain,
and Scheele in Sweden.
And all three of them were
working simultaneously to
study combustion and
understand oxygen.
And here I've got a
very nice image.
This is a portrait of Lavoisier
with his wife.
And it's hard to see.
If the lights were a little
bit dimmer, you'd see--
notice here, you see all of
this chemical apparatus.
There is bell jars, and various
glass apparatus.
His wife was his partner
in the laboratory.
She was unique among
French women in
that she read English.
And in his rivalry with
Priestley, he relied on his
wife in order to read
Priestley's writings.
So they worked together.
She even helped him
in the laboratory.
They married at the time he
was 27 and she was 13, and
they were--
what are you so shocked about?
It's France, and it's 1779!
Get over it!
Anyways, she helped him a lot,
and we'll say a little bit
more about that later.
OK.
So now let's go on to the next
part of the history lesson.
So so far, we've got one
explanation, and it's wrong.
So let's go to the next one,
and we'll go to Britain.
Sir Humphry Davy in
London in 1810.
So we'll put GB here, and he's
driving around in his little
Jaguar, I suspect.
And he said something
that was correct.
He said that it's hydrogen
present in all acids.
And that was pretty much it.
He was a great scientist, did
some very good work, but
really didn't do anything
quantitative here.
So for the quantitative stuff,
we have to wait for almost the
end of the century.
And we go up to Sweden
again, to Arrhenius.
And Arrhenius, in 1887--
so I'll give him a Volvo.
And he said that the acid is a
substance that disassociates
to produce protons.
So the acid is defined as a
solution that dissociates to
give protons.
I'm going to say H plus, meaning
the hydrogen ion, or P
plus, and we're going to keep
using the term proton.
I'm not going to say hydrogen
ion, I'm going to say proton.
So proton in solution.
So this is what he defines.
And he further defines
the base.
He defines the base as the
complement to the acid.
And he says that the base is
something that dissociates to
give us hydroxyl.
The base dissociates to give
OH minus the hydroxyl.
And so now we've got this whole
concept of electrolytic
disassociation, which is what
wins him the Nobel prize in
1903 for this thing.
And then we saw last day how the
addition of ions to water
gives charge carriers.
And so the presence of protons
and hydroxyl is, in fact, the
way we have any charge carried
through water.
So up until now, when I said
electrical conductivity, we
were pretty much referring to
electronic conductivity.
But there's a second kind of
conductivity, and we can have
ionic conductivity.
Ionic conductivity, as the
name implies, is not by
electrons, but by ions.
And this is typically
ions in solution.
Ionic conductivity in solution,
and a solution that
is an ionic conductor is
called an electrolyte.
So we have electrolyte
in our bodies,
saline, about 5% chloride.
We have electrolyte in batteries
that are ionically
conductive.
And the term simply means, we
have conduction by ions.
And so it was the theory of
electrolytic dissociation that
won the Nobel prize.
So how does this work?
So we can start with something
like HCl gas.
I'm going to dissolve it in
water, and this will give me
proton, H plus.
And I'm going to write aq,
meaning that it's dissolved in
water, and the chloride ion,
also dissolved in water.
And so this gives me an acid.
This is a proton donor.
And now let's look at
something like sodium hydroxide.
Sodium hydroxide at room
temperature is an ionic
compound, so it is a solid, but
it is soluble in a polar,
hydrogen-bonded liquid, so H20,
to give hydroxyl aqueous
plus sodium ion aqueous.
So again, we see the
dissociation.
And then we can have,
from here, a
neutralization reaction.
And the neutralization
reaction is simply
reconstitution of the solvent.
So neutralization, another way
to think about it, because
we're not going to be confined
to water by the end of the
lecture, neutralization is
simply a reaction that results
in reconstitution
of the solvents.
So the solvent, in this
case, is water.
So how would we reconstitute
water?
We combine proton
with hydroxyl.
So let's do that and see the
result of that reaction.
So if I take, and run it in the
vertical direction, proton
plus hydroxyl, we'll
give water again--
let's give H20 liquid--
and now you can see Na
plus Cl will give me
NaCl, aqueous dissolved.
So this is what you probably
learned in your high school
chemistry, that acid plus base
ca give you salt plus water.
So you see all of this resulting
from just the simple
Arrhenius definition.
So this is good.
We've got off to a decent start
here with Arrhenius.
But then the theory has its
limitations, as they all do.
And how do we discover
the limitations?
With some new data.
So let's look at some data.
So it had been known for a long
time that ammonia, when
it's dissolved in water, can act
as a solution capable of
neutralizing an acid.
So if ammonia dissolved in water
neutralizes an acid,
then this must be a base.
But look, there's no
hydroxyl here.
So the Arrhenius definition
of base is inadequate
to account for this.
So let's just get that down.
Ammonia, which you know is a gas
at room temperature, will
neutralize acids.
But no hydroxyl present.
So something's going on here
that we can't account for by
the simple Arrhenius
definition.
So to get us out of this
conundrum, we had to wait
until 1923.
And two scientists
simultaneously enunciated the
same ideas.
So I'm going to put
them both down.
1923.
Bronsted, who was in Denmark,
and Lowry, who was
working in the UK.
Also 1923.
And I'll give him a
Jaguar as well.
And so the two of them proposed
a broader definition
to account for what's
going on here.
And what did they say?
They said that acid--
they'll keep the same definition
as Arrhenius.
So an acid is going to
be a proton donor.
So that's good.
Let's even put here,
same as Arrhenius.
But now here's the difference.
The base is no longer confined
to hydroxyl chemistry.
They call it a proton
acceptor.
And that's different.
So hydroxyl-free.
Now, let's be careful here.
If I propose this new
definition, I
can't throw out hydroxyl.
So you've got to watch to make
sure that by broadening the
definition, we don't
exclude hydroxyl.
So the theory has to encompass
what we already know, and then
continue to encompass things
that tend to contradict what
we already know.
So let's take a look at
what this gives us.
So I'm going to write a
broader equation here.
I'm going to write
this as the acid.
So what do I have?
I have every acid has
to have a proton in
it, plus some residual.
So I can rewrite the
acid in this form.
I'm going to react
it with a base.
So according to this definition,
this has to be a
proton donor.
And this, you're going to
watch me on this one.
This is going to be
a proton acceptor.
And we'll put some
identities here.
Eventually we're going to write
this with ammonia in it,
but let's just do the
broad definition.
So what happens is, if this is
a proton acceptor, on this
side of the equation, it takes
the proton from here.
This is the proton donor.
It gives it away, and we
end up with a BH plus.
So this proton acceptor has
accepted the proton, leaving
behind the deprotonated
A minus.
That's a nice little reaction.
But now, if you'd nodded off for
the last 90 seconds, and
then opened your eyes and said,
well, he said acid is a
proton donor, this thing
can give up a proton.
So OK, I'm going to call this
thing a proton donor.
And this is most certainly
a proton acceptor.
Look, it has accepted
the proton.
So this is going to be
a proton acceptor.
So now I've got in this equation
two proton donors and
two proton acceptors.
And they're linked.
This proton donor, BH plus,
is linked to B.
So I'm going to put a little
yolk over this one.
And this HA, the original
acid, is linked to
this base, A minus.
So I'm going to put
a yoke over that.
And the Latin word for yoke, to
yoke, is jugere, from which
we get the word conjugate.
So I'm going to call
these things
conjugate acid-base pairs.
And every equation has two.
Because you've got a proton
donor proton acceptor.
So now this is, follow
the bouncing ball.
If you want to understand
acid-base chemistry, just
follow the proton.
Here's proton here,
goes over here.
Here's something deprotonated,
now it's protonated.
That's the rhythm here.
So the whole thing is, acid-base
reactions can be
defined as a proton transfer
reactions.
Remember we talked about
ionicity and electron transfer
in order to achieve
octet stability?
So we saw the whole
life and times of
electron transfer reactions.
Now life and times of proton
transfer reactions.
OK.
And last thing I want to do, is
to just make sure that we
see the definitions.
You know, all queens are female,
but not all females
are queens.
So this one here, what's this?
This is definitely, it's
a proton donor.
So it's an acid.
So it's definitely an Arrhenius
acid, because it's
got a proton, and it's also
a Bronsted-Lowry acid.
Now, what about this one?
This is a base.
It may not have hydroxyl
in it.
May or may not.
So this is definitely a
Bronsted-Lowry base, but I
can't say for sure that it's
an Arrhenius base, because
Arrhenius has to be O minus.
This one here, what
about this?
Unless it's OH minus, this
one here is, what?
It's Bronsted-Lowry base.
And this one here, this can be
both Bronsted-Lowry acid and
it can be an Arrhenius acid.
So this is how we can
differentiate them.
OK, good.
Now let's go to the ammonia, see
if we've got ourselves out
of the conundrum so we
can write now NH3.
And I'm going to say that
this is ammonia
that's already dissolved.
So ammonia is already in aqueous
solution, and it
reacts with water, H20
liquid, to do what?
This is supposed to be a--
if this is a base, remember,
this is the thing that we're
trying to demonstrate.
If it's a base, according to
this, it's a proton acceptor.
So I'm going to stick a proton
on this, and I'm going to get
NH4 plus the ammonium ion.
And how did I get the
ammonium ion?
I took a proton from water,
leaving behind OH.
So can you see that how
this thing works?
By gobbling up protons, by
becoming a proton vacuum
cleaner, it takes protons
out of water, leaving
an excess of hydroxyl.
And in effect, now we've got
something that's tantamount to
an Arrhenius base.
But it all started
off with this.
So now we can link these two.
I'm going to yoke ammonium
and ammonia as conjugate
acid-base, and there is
water and hydroxyl
as acid-base pairs.
So again, let's get
the colors going.
Here we've got Bronsted-Lowry--
the bases are always going
to be in blue.
Blue and base both begin
with the letter B.
So this is definitely
Brosted-Lowry base, but it's
not an Arrhenius base.
This is a Bronsted-Lowry
base, and it's also
an Arrhenius base.
This one here, we can
call this one--
in this case, it's a proton
donor, so it's both an
Arrhenius acid and a
Bronsted-Lowry acid.
But look at this.
You'd say, OK, I know
what he's doing.
Arrheius, Bronsted-Lowry,
Arrhenius, Bronsted-Lowry.
This is Bronsted-Lowry
only, this must be
Bronsted-Lowry only.
But look!
This is a proton donor.
It dissociates to
give protons.
So this is both Bronsted-Lowry
and Arrhenius.
Most people will miss that.
We'll get to see, maybe, on a
subsequent celebration, how
many of you miss that.
OK.
So.
So now, let's go into
the chemistry here.
Because I said up here at the
beginning of the lecture--
what is it-- bonding is the
key to understanding.
So what is it about bonding
here that defines the
Bronsted-Lowry base?
So I'm going to write this
reaction in this way, now.
I'm going to put-- here's
the proton, which
is coming from water.
And I'm going to write
that with NH3.
I'm going to use the
Lewis structure.
So, you know, Lewis structure
looks like this, Nitrate has
got five valence electrons,
three of them are bound, and
now I've got this long pair.
So what do we know about
the electronic
structure of proton?
What does it look like?
What's the Lewis structure
of proton?
How many electrons on proton?
None.
This is nothing.
This is very needy.
It's like the neediest friend
you have. You know, the one
that's always taking stuff
from you, taking your
emotional energy, giving
back nothing?
That's proton.
That's the human equivalent
of proton.
So if proton wants to make a
bond to form NH4, proton is
going to come over here and
exploit both electrons.
So if this is going to be a
proton acceptor, the only way
it can be a proton acceptor
is to have two
unused electrons available.
This is going to be a
dative bond, agreed?
Dative, because both electrons
from the bond
come from the nitrogen.
The proton doesn't contribute
anything.
So that's the hallmark.
The proton acceptor
axiomatically must have an
available non-bonding pair.
So wherever you see non-bonding
pairs, wherever
you see a compound that has
this capability, it could
serve as a Bronsted-Lowry
base.
We know that water, because it
has hydroxyl in it, has to
satisfy this.
So let's take a look.
H20 we can do similarly.
Oxygen.
It's got 6 electrons, 2 are in
the, bonds and we have 2
non-bonding pairs.
So then when we attach
proton here, we make
something called hydronium.
We make hydronium ion.
So it's a little fancier than
just saying, I've got this
naked proton with no electrons
swimming around in water.
In fact, it's more coordinated
like this.
H30 plus, and while we're
in the neighborhood, we
might as well show.
This is sp3 hybridized.
We've got one, two, three,
four orbitals.
Hydrogen's on three.
It's got a net charge of
plus 1, and lone pair
on the fourth side.
So there's the structure
of hydronium.
And we can now write
the equation.
We can say H20 liquid plus
H20 liquid gives me H3O
plus, plus OH minus.
So this is now the
self-ionization or
self-dissociation reaction.
So now I can pair
these as well.
I can yoke these.
I have acid-base pair.
So this is acid here, and the
conjugate base is water, H20.
Hydroxyl, we know, has
to be a base, and its
conjugate acid is water.
So you see, in the same
equation, same place, same
time, water is acting as both
acid and base relative to
these two species.
And so we call such a such a
compound that acts as both
acid and base, we call
it amphipathic.
Has two moods.
You know, amphi, like
in amphitheater.
Have you ever seen
a Roman theater?
It looks like this from
the top down.
It's got all this, you know,
like this, and all the people
are here, and there's
the stage up here.
But if I make a theater in the
round, that is amphitheater.
Or as it's commonly
mispronounced, ampitheater.
3091ers do not say ampitheater,
they say
amphitheater.
So this reaction here is
self-dissociation.
Right?
This reaction is
self-dissociation of water.
Or because we're forming
ions, it's also called
self-ionization.
Self-dissociation or
self-ionization of water.
Now, turns out that the
chemical's power of H3O plus
and OH minus is very high.
So this reaction doesn't go
very far to the right.
The amount of the dissociation
is tiny, and to be specific,
at 25 degrees C, the amount
of, if you take deionized,
deaerated water, absolutely
pure and pristine.
The amount of native H30 plus
and OH minus is on the order
of one part in 10 million.
So H3O plus concentration
would be 10
to the minus 7 molar.
And obviously, from the
stoichiometry of the equation,
you get the identical
amount of OH minus.
Well, that's in the
self-dissociation.
And so you have very, very few
charge carriers, which is why
high-purity water is a very poor
conductor of electricity,
even as an electrolyte.
And that's, I've told you in
the past, that could be one
indicator of certain toxins.
If you measure the conductivity
of water and you
discover it's abnormally high,
and it's putatively supposed
to be pure water, that's
an indication that
it's not pure water.
There's some other charge
carriers present.
So we can write a
Ksp we analogy.
And it's called the water
ionization constant, which is
the product H3O plus
and OH minus.
And you can do the math.
That's 10 to the minus
14 is the product.
And you can use the common
ion effect here.
If I introduce some other
acid, look at how this
equation helps you the same
way that Ksp did.
If I have acid, in other words,
protons donated from
some other source, that means
this number is going to be
higher than 10 to the minus 7.
If this number is higher than
10 to the minus 7, and the
product must be 10 to the minus
14, this must be lower.
So when I have, H3O plus goes
up, then OH minus must go
down, and under these
circumstances, we have
something that is called
proton-rich.
And we call this acid, simply
because the proton
concentration exceeds
the hydroxyl.
And likewise for the other.
And so we can make a plot of
this, and that's shown here.
And all we've got is
OH versus H3O plus.
And you can see that it's
a right hyperbola.
But it goes back to that comment
that I made in the
past about how you graph data.
I don't know what to do with
that, because it's curved.
I can't tell whether the
data are good or bad.
So instead of looking at
something like this, y versus
x, I want to transform so that
can get a straight line.
Because then I can make a
judgment about goodness
of fit and so on.
So I need some f of x versus
g of y to, quote unquote,
straighten this out.
And we have that, thanks
to another Dane,
by the name of Sorensen.
Sorensen was the one that
gave us another way
to think about it.
Sorensen, who in 1901, and
he's got the DK on his--
he's probably got
a Volvo, too.
Or maybe he's driving a Saab.
So he was a biochemist at
the Carlsberg brewery.
Yes, they had biochemists,
because they wanted understand
the chemistry of beer
production.
What a concept.
Having people that
understand the
technology of the business.
So he was working at the
Carlsberg brewery, and he
decided to take this acid-base
business and turn it into
something that's much more
readily recognizable.
And so he defined a concept
called the chemical potential,
which, if you like, is the
reactivity, the chemical
potential of hydronium.
And he gave it the symbol.
Lowercase p for potential, and
uppercase H as, obviously, for
the hydrogen ion.
And he said, I'm going to
make this a logarithm.
So it's logarithm, and in those
days, everybody was
using slide rules, so it's log
base 10 of the concentration
of hydronium.
And being a good engineer, he
recognized since this starts
off at 10 to the minus 7, the
log of a number less than one
is going to be negative.
And who wants to deal with
negative numbers?
So you put a minus sign here.
That way, pH normally is
a positive number.
And now you can see the
results of Sorensen's
straightening things
out for us.
So now you go over a wider
range, and you can see, you
have nice straight line
relationship, and then you can
get data on there, and so on.
And this is taken from your
book, and it shows the pH
values of some common
substances.
If you start here at neutral pH
7, you have milk, you have
human blood, normal things that
you would expect, fluids
and so on, are hovering
around 7.
If you take some coffee, you're
going to go into the
acidic region.
You see tomatoes down
here at about 4.
Wine, you'll see in the reviews
of wines, they'll say
it has balanced acidity
and so on.
Yeah, it's down around pH 3.
And carbonated soft drinks, some
of them get down to 2.
Vinegar is wine that
has spoiled.
Vin aigre, which means eager.
The Middle French eager meant
impetuous, or tart, or something.
So this is spoiled wine.
And the pH changes.
So by measuring the pH of wine,
you can tell if it's
changing or not.
There's lemon juice.
Gastric juices in the stomach
can get down to 1, pH of 1.
But you want that happening
only at one point in the
digestive cycle.
If you run around for long
periods of time at pH 1, you
will ulcerate, in other words,
you'll puncture the walls.
And if that's about to happen,
you need to neutralize.
So how do you neutralize?
You go up with something
that has a high pH.
So you can start with something
like Alka-Seltzer,
sodium bicarbonate at
about 8.4, or milk
of magnesia, 10.5.
Why is it milk of magnesia?
From last day, because it's
not a solution, it is a
suspension.
The magnesia is in suspension.
The magnesium hydroxide.
And that's one of those
mandatory shake well before
using, because all the magnesia
is on the bottom, and
you've got this almost clear,
colorless liquid on the top.
So you're just drinking water.
Not going to help you if you've
got stomach pain, but
gastric juice is down here.
If you're really desperate,
don't reach for ammonia.
You have to be patient.
They have to work with
milk of magnesia.
OK.
So that's the range.
So what else do we have here?
Let's take a look.
So far we've been assuming that
when we add acid to the
system, we get 1 to
1 dissociation.
So the next message that I want
to give you here, is that
not all acids are of
equal strength.
See, I could look up here and
say, well, maybe the reason
that the lemon juice is down it
at 2 and the gastric juices
are at 1 is simply a
concentration effect.
How much acid was introduced.
No, there's another explanation
for it.
And that is that certain acids
don't fully disassociate.
So for example, if we look at
1 molar HCl, hydrochloric
acid, you look at 1 molar
hydrochloric acid, that goes
100% into solution and gives
us 1 molar H30 plus.
So 1 to 1 correspondence between
how much hydrochloric
acid we introduce, and how much
hydroxyl that we generate.
So this is total dissociation
of the HCl.
And as a result, we call
this a strong acid.
In contrast, let me show
you a weak acid.
So a weak acid is going to
dissolve, but it doesn't
dissociate.
So there's really
two steps here.
First you've got to get the
stuff in solution, and then
once you get it in solution,
it has to break apart.
It's possible to go into
solution and not break apart.
In which case, you don't have
the protons, but you've got
the solution.
That's not an acid.
So a weak acid would be,
let's, in contrast,
look at a weak acid.
A weak acid would be something
like acetic
acid, which is CH3COOH.
And this is for historical
reasons.
Normally, the proton that's
going to dissociate is at the
front of the formula, but this
was written long ago, before
people understood this theory.
And that's the way you'll
see acetic acid written.
So really, this is the proton,
and the CH3COO is really the
acetate anion, Ac,
acetate anion.
So we're going to put that
into solution, like this.
I'm going to put it into
water, H20 liquid.
So this is the salt out of
solution, and all we're going
to do is make it into the
aqueous solution of same COOH,
and I'm just going
to write aq.
Now, if this were strong acid
with impunity, I would write
whatever the concentration of
acetic acid is, I break it
apart, and I get the full
amount of the proton.
What happens is that this, now
plus H20, gives me H3O plus
plus the remaining acetate,
which is CH3COO minus.
And now, here's where the
weakness is manifested.
The degree to which the acetic
acid grabs protons from here,
and then ends up being
protonated,
is very, very small.
It turns out that in the
case of 1 molar--
I'm going to write acetic
acid this way, now.
HAc.
So this thing here is the
CH3COO minus, all right?
It turns out that in 1
molar acetic acid, we
get only 0.4% reaction.
0.4% reacts and dissociates.
So to give protons, it hangs
onto most of its protons.
So we can then represent this
in the form of an acid
dissociation constant.
And that it looks like this.
K sub a for acid.
So on the right side, what we're
going to do is make a
mass balance here.
We're going to take the product
of the proton, the
acetate divided by the
undisassociated acetic acid.
So we'll put H3O plus
concentration times the
acetate concentration
divided by the
undissociated HAc aqueous.
So I'm trying to represent
what the ratio is here.
And instead of being one to one,
it's 10 to the minus 5.
Very, very weak.
You get a little bit,
but not much.
Now, you could say, well, 10 to
the minus 5, this is, just
for reference, it's 100 times
10 to the minus 7,
which is the Kw.
So the point here is, if you put
in acetic acid, you'll end
up with 100 times the proton
population that you would have
had by just self-dissociation.
So it isn't acid.
It is donating protons.
But it's not doing it a lot.
So this is called a weak
acid, because it's
a poor proton donor.
And so we can then look
at a comparison to,
say, over here, HCl.
Let's go back here, and we can
write the acid dissociation
constant for HCl, for
the strong acid.
And in that case, Ka over here,
which is going to be the
H3O plus Cl minus, H3O plus.
In the case of HCl, we're
going to get proton and
chloride over undissociated
HCl dissolved in water.
And that's 10 to the plus 6,
which for all intents and
purposes is infinity.
You put in 1 molar HCl, you
get 1 molar H plus.
And look at the ratio.
10 to the sixth, 10
to the minus 5.
There's a 10 to the eleventh
relationship between the weak
acid and the strong acid.
And here's the cartoon that
shows this strong acid, put in
this amount, 100% dissociation,
weak acid gives
you small amounts of proton,
and a very weak acid is
imperceptible amount
of disassociation.
And here's a table that
quantifies it.
So the strong acids up
here with the Ka.
This value of Ka has to be
greater than 1, because it's
saying that we're getting a
lot of dissociation, the
reactions moving to the right.
And you have these
numbers here.
10 to the ninth, 10 to the
eighth, 10 to the sixth.
Those are differences
without distinction.
if I say the ratio is a million
to one, or a billion
to one, for all intents
and purposes, you have
dissociation.
And then here are
the week acids.
Look.
10 to the minus 3.
There's phosphoric,
hydrofluoric, and so on, all
the way down.
There's carbonic acid,
10 to the minus 7.
So there's the list.
And just another cute
demonstration of the
relationship between bonding and
acidity, the acid strength
increases from left to right,
and the bond strength
increases from right to left.
You know, HF is very strong.
It's a hydrogen-bonded.
Very tight HF bond.
But what determines if
it's going to be a
strong acid or not?
It's how willing HF is
to give up its H.
But its H is tightly bound.
So oddly enough, in HF, you
don't give up much of the H.
HF is over here.
It's less than one.
It's a weak acid.
HCl is a pretty strong acid.
If you want to go heavy-duty,
HBr and HI are even stronger
acids, because they have a
weaker hold on the hydrogen
within them, so they
are much, much more
generous proton donors.
So you can see that from there.
OK.
So what's the takeaway
message here?
The takeaway message is that
equal acid concentration does
not mean equal acid strength.
You have to be mediated
by the Ka.
Equal acid concentration,
which means, how
much did you dissolve?
Does not equal acid strength.
And what's the reason?
Because equal acid
concentration, this is a
function of solubility, whereas
this is a function of
dissociation.
So many dissolve,
few dissociate.
How about that?
There's a nice tagline
you can use.
Use that at a party
this weekend.
Many dissolve, but
few dissociate.
All right.
Now I want to go very,
very high.
Big concept, all right?
Last definition of acid-base
comes from the United States.
G.
N.
Lewis.
Same G.
N.
Lewis who gave us the Lewis
cross and dot structures,
covalent bonding, didn't
stop inventing.
So we're going to put U.S.A.,
with a Chevrolet out in
California.
And what did G.
N.
Lewis tell us?
He said, I want to extend the
Bronsted-Lowry concept.
But you know, let me give
you an analogy.
Have you ever stood
on a bridge and
watched the traffic go?
You see it starts from a stop
sign or a traffic light.
Light turns green, the first car
pulls away, the second car
pulls away, the third
car pulls away.
The other way you can look at
it is, when the first car
pulls away, there's
a car vacancy.
And instead of watching the cars
go from right to left,
watch the car vacancy move
from left to right.
And the two are linked.
And point of fact, if you're
the fourth car from the
traffic light, light
turns green and you
hit the horn, why?
You can't drive.
You have to drive only into a
car vacancy, and it takes time
for the car vacancy
to get to you.
When the rate of vacancy flux is
not matched by the rate of
car flux, then we have a
collision, and then we
exchange papers.
So it's a mass transport
problem.
So now what G.
N.
Lewis said was, instead of
looking at this reaction as a
proton transfer reaction, and
looking at proton attachment,
or proton acquisition, he said,
why don't we look at
this from the other side
of the relationship?
And so he said, let's look at
something like, for example,
we've got NH3 here.
So let's put the N with
the 2 electrons.
And we've been talking about
this from the perspective of
the bond being formed
here through the
acquisition of the proton.
Lewis said, I can view this from
the other perspective,
and say, I'm going to
view it from the
perspective of the nitrogen.
From the perspective of the
nitrogen, this reaction
represents the donation
of the electron pair.
A very high concept.
So this base is not about
proton attachment.
It's about donating an
electronic pair.
So let's get that down, because
that's really good.
So I'm going to say something
that's a base looks like this.
This is what a base is.
It's a lone pair.
This is electron pair,
very high level base.
And what's the proton give us?
What we're doing, is
we're talking about
electrons and donation.
So what's this other thing
in that same category?
An electron pair can match
up with an empty orbital.
That's the only place electron
pairs can go.
They go to the empty orbitals.
So electron pair is a base,
and this is just a circle
around nothing.
OK?
This is nothing.
But it's a special
kind of nothing.
This is called a
vacant orbital.
And I'm going to call a vacant
orbital an acid, in the most
general sense.
So now I'm going to take an
electron pair plus vacant
orbital, and what did they
react to give me?
Covalent bond.
You'd expect that from G.
N.
Lewis, because G.
Lewis enunciated covalency.
That's why you'd expect
it from G.
N.
Lewis.
So this is, vacant orbital
plus electron pair gives
covalent bond.
Very high level.
So what is a base?
A base is now not just
a proton acceptor.
It's an electron pair donor,
and the acid is an electron
pair acceptor.
So now there's no
chemistry here.
No chemical identities.
Which means, I can
even go from--
I don't even have to
be in solution.
I don't have to be
in a liquid.
This could be a gas
and a solid.
Could be a gas plus a gas.
So this is, like, Darwinian.
You know, we've come out of the
primordial ooze, and now
we can fly, because we can
talk about any chemical
reaction we want.
Any state of matter.
It's fantastic.
Absolutely fantastic.
So here, let me do one
last color drawing.
We want to do this one here.
This is Lewis and the
biggest concept.
So we're going to
go like this.
Base like this.
Base with its lone
pair hanging out
plus acid gives us--
three colors.
This is great.
We've got all this colored
chalk, it's Friday,
what could be better.
All right.
So now we're going to end up
with A, B, there it is.
This is the Lewis concept.
Lewis acid-base concept.
In the broadest thing.
Now I'm going to show
you an example of
how you can use this.
I'm not going to stop here.
OK, let's go.
All right.
So we're going to talk
about acid rain
from burning of coal.
You know, about half of the
electric power in this country
comes from burning coal, and
coal contains about 1% sulfur.
You can purify it of sulfur, but
it takes money to do so.
A ton of coal will give you
about 25 million British
thermal units, and that's the
number in SI units and joules.
So 3 tons of coal will give
you 1 megawatt per day.
By the way, it takes about
one gram of uranium
to do the same thing.
So someday, when you're
sitting there as a
policymaker, you've got a choice
of 3 tons of coal or
one gram of uranium, keep
this fact in mind.
A 10 megawatt plant burns
30 tons of coal per day,
containing a third of a ton of
sulphur, which makes 2/3 of a
ton of SO2.
And SO2 is a precursor
to acid rain.
Now we can reduce that SO2
emissions by reacting SO2 with
a lime, CaO, according
to this reaction, to
make calcium sulfite.
And now I'm going to
bring in this.
Lewis.
Oh, here's from your textbook,
there's the scrubbers with the
calcium oxide, and water
missed, and so on, and
eventually they trap the SO2.
They do nothing to the CO2.
So all the CO2 is going up.
So here's calcium oxide,
which is a solid.
It's lime.
You know, stuff you sprinkle
on football fields.
And this is SO2, and it's got
this structure with the
resident bond double single.
The oxygen here acts the
way it did in the
glasses, as a modifier.
It goes in and breaks this
double bond, and now we have
three single bonds.
So we can look at this
from Lewis acid-base.
You know, calcium oxides,
electron pair donor.
If it's an electron pair
donor, it's a base.
So it's a base.
And you know SO2 better be an
acid, or your theory is nuts,
because SO2 is a precursor
to acid rain.
So it has to be an acid.
It's an electronic
pair acceptor,
which is what we said.
It's an electron
pair acceptor.
So this is a Lewis acid-base
reaction that
is a gas-solid reaction.
So we started with aqueous
solutions, and we end up
generalizing all of these
types of reactions.
So that's pretty good.
Here's a plot of acid
concentration
up in the sky, here.
You're Here.
Yeah.
Last thing I'll do, I talked
a lot about Lavoisier and
Scheele and Priestley.
This is a play, if you've
got the little bit
of time this weekend.
You might try reading it.
This is Carl Djerassi and Roald
Hoffman, both Nobel
Prize winners in Chemistry.
Not the same year.
They won independent Nobel
Prizes, and actually speak to
each other, and they
collaborated on this play.
Here's the setup, the premise.
The premise of the play is
that the Nobel committee
decides to give Nobel
Prizes retrograde.
Before 1901.
You see, you can't get a Nobel
Prize posthumously.
You've got to do something
great, and you've got to keep
on living until you
get the prize.
So they decided they're going
to go backwards, you know,
maybe give prizes to people
like, I don't know, Maxwell or
Faraday or whatever.
And they decide, it should be
simple in the old days.
Because we didn't have all this
dog-eat-dog competition
in science, and big grants,
and corporate interests.
Should be simple.
Until they hit the Nobel Prize
for the discovery of oxygen.
And then they hit the wall with
these three different
competitors.
And so the story goes that the
three competitors and their
wives end up in Stockholm,
and the
interactions the take place.
And it's really fascinating,
because you have Lavoisier,
who was the political
conservative but the chemical
radical, Priestley, who was the
chemical radical but the
political conservative--
by the way, Lavoisier.
You know how he died?
He was guillotined during
the French revolution.
And people think it's because
he was a tax collector.
Not true.
He was a tax collector.
The real reason is Marat, who
was one of the chief justices
of the Jacobin terror, was also
a scientist. And around
1740, Marat had submitted an
article for publication, and
it was rejected.
And Lavoisier was on the
editorial board.
And so sometimes when I get an
article to review, and I have
to give it a negative review,
I think about this story.
And sometimes, I will just say,
you know, I'm really busy
teaching 3091 and I won't get
to this on a timely basis.
OK, people.
Have a nice weekend.